[Applaudissements]
allons accueillir notre première invitée
c'est carole rousseau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci d'être là car si on gagne un petit
peu de funk à carole rousseau vous aimez
la funky music et carole rousseau qui
viennent nous voir ya le grand concours
des animateurs le samedi 21 septembre je
crois que cette question je pense qu'il
restera dans les annales de l'émission
vous avez la funky music
le gars est persuadé qu'il anime le hit
machine est bas dans un resto on recevra
des coulées de boue alors vous devons
être animés de groix compo la compagnie
créole c'est vrai en anniversaire sur un
plateau il ya très très longtemps et qui
s'était j'ai plus qu'à des missions mais
vous avez pensé sur la compagnie gol non
écoutez si vous danser avec moi pourquoi
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
calvignac une de mes émissions préférées
ce sport
les téléspectateurs qui nous regardent
l'aiment beaucoup elle cartonne c'est le
grand concours des animateurs on a
toujours adoré quand vous y participiez
à maui et mais moi surtout merci merci
carreau mais j'aurais voulu participer
cette fois ci on n'a pas pu avec valérie
mairesse que nous étions tout à fait
mais bien dans l'airé à coucher ce soir
la fin personne c'est à coucher que pas
tort elle accouché quelques avec sa
tenue bien entendu carole on va voir la
bande-annonce du grand concours des
animateurs on en parle juste après mais
c'est vrai que c'est une émission qui
cartonne sur tf1 on va en parler avec gl
gérard louvin